the allegations that Harry has made in
the latest three episodes of the
docu-series are so personal towards his
brother within four hours they're happy
to lie
to protect my brother
and yet for three years they were never
willing to tell the truth to protect us
even if William hasn't watched this docu
series and it's my understanding that he
hasn't he'll be very aware of the
headlines he'll be very aware of the
damage inflicted on his reputation and I
think it also goes a long way into
explaining why the brothers are not on
talking terms quite simply William feels
betrayed I mean this is a couple who are
never far away from their iPhone from
their cameras who have really chronicled
their lives for the last two years and I
think there is just a great sense of
mistrust within the family they just
simply feel that any reconciliation is
not on the cards because they can't they
can't trust that it's not going to end
up in a TV show or in a book I think
tempers are high and there's a lot of
tension there's a lot of upset there's a
lot of anger and there's still a lot of
resentment and I think any reproachment
is is really quite far down the line
Willie will be taking this very
personally I think he's incredibly upset
and feel feels very badly betrayed by
his brother
wow
Facebook's brother there's a tantalizing
moment in one of the episodes where
Harry shows Megan a text that he says is
from William on his phone we don't get
to see that text one can only imagine
that it was not a friendly text we know
that William was apoplectic over the
allegations of racism that the couple
made in that Oprah interview my biggest
takeaway is that this seems to be an
attempt to take down the royal family an
attempt by Harry and Megan to really
cast the monarchy in the most negative
of Lights to make it look out of touch
archaic uncaring unsupportive racist
it's it's an attack on the monarchy
he's opened Pandora's Box in this docu
series but he certainly hasn't emptied
that box I think there is a lot more
that he can say there is a lot more
damage potentially that could be done
[Music]